Tonie people want to know what is your
morning routine I'm like an athlete you
got to Train your nervous system
besides physically working out I also
trained my mind to do in my emotions to
do what's the most difficult and I do
that all kinds of ways I like to play at
my edge that's how you get better so I
put my demands myself but the first
thing I do every morning is part of that
ritual is I jump into Jacuzzi which
losing the muscles and then I jump in
freezing cold water I have a cold plunge
if he would it's 57 degrees and I hop
into that thing
I also for recovery sake I use
cryotherapy which was developed in
Europe it's amazing a lot of athletes
around the world are using it now and it
lowers your body temperature using
nitrogen so there's no water on your you
would freeze it up or you would burn by
using these gases it brings the
temperature down your body down to minus
225 Fahrenheit which is my wild for
three minutes and what it does is it
like resets your whole nervous system
and it takes all the inflammation out of
your body so I'm on stage I will do 27
miles on my most intense day of a
three-day program so I'm doing like
multiple days an ultra marathon because
I'm not standing there talking I mean
people would not come if people would
sit for three hour movie someone spent
300 million dollars on to make for two
hours they're gonna stay with me for 50
hours over weekend I gotta deliver right
and I got you know the Paul Tudor Jones
is the world in there the Oprah
Winfrey's in the Oprah tells me Tony I
love you but I can't see anywhere for
more than two hours in the end of 12
hours you stand your chair going on
camera this is one the greatest
experience in my life well to do that
you're gonna stand still I'm plunging
the audience I'm doing things I'm
spontaneous so that's a lot of miles so
I'm literally doing one marathon I go
into this machine and three minutes
later I come out the next day it's like
instead of all these aches and pains and
tears I'm recovered so I'm always
looking for technology that can enhance
my ability to perform and produce great
results and also stay healthy thank you
guys so much for watching you mentioned
before that you like seen the morning
routine series we've continued it for
you I'd love to know what you think of
Tony's routine I'd love to know what
your morning routine looks like as well
leave both in the comments below I'll
join in the discussion thanks again for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you